hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see that there are a bunch of
questions here
waiting
uh let's start off with when i see at
the top here from eddie
um considering visual perception
discontinuous or discrete can we
consider quantized in that case could it
be calculated as discrete packets of
visual perception based on quantum
physics
oh boy
okay so
first thing to say is
that
uh when we think about light our eyes
are sensing light
and
the way that our eyes sense light
is that the retina the back of our eye
has photosensitive cells and in those
cells there are protein molecules that
have the feature that if a packet of
light
hits that protein molecule
it causes it to
essentially produce a piece of electric
current produce an electron that is then
uh
that uh
then
causes
electrical activity in our nerve and our
optic nerve again then goes to our brain
that then causes us to have the
sensation of seeing something
okay so
at some level
our visual perception
is necessarily discrete because
what it comes about by a packet of light
hitting a specific molecule on our
retina and producing a specific
electrical effect
and um
now i set a packet of light because i'm
kind of hedging that the question is
what what is light kind of made of
um and
is is light a sort of continuous sort of
wave of electromagnetic radiation or is
it broken into discrete sort of
corpuscles discrete particles well what
quantum mechanics tells us is that we
can think about it in either way we can
think about it either
as this kind of stream of particles
photons whose
whose characteristics we can only figure
out on average
but we can think of the light as being
broken down into individual photons it's
just that when we sense those photons we
only sense them in some average way so
that's choice number one
choice number two is the idea that light
is part of this continuous field this
this wave of electrical effects and
magnetic effects that are producing uh
that that are that are
that represent light and that's those
two
points of view
one of the discoveries of quantum
mechanics
in uh well this was really in the 1920s
um was that those two points of view
kind of give you mathematically the same
results when you ask what is the
perception of a piece of light the it
doesn't really matter whether you think
about the light as being this wave or
whether you think about it as being
these discrete photons um you get when
you're looking at the mathematical
effect of how an observer of the light
senses the light you get the same
consequences in those two cases
but
in terms of
the way we think about something like a
uh the um
rhodopsin is the name of the protein
that is
that is responsible for
uh i guess i have that right i think um
the uh
that
is responsible for sensing light on our
retina
but that really operates but it's best
to think about that in terms of a single
photon of light hits the protein
molecule it causes it to
to uh eject a single electron that then
goes and produces electrical activity on
our optic nerve
okay so one of the questions that one
might then ask is
if it is the case that there are these
discrete sort of uh
pieces of light these discrete photons
that we sense um that that are
responsible for what we sense in our
eyes how come it looks like there's sort
of continuous
uh levels of light in our eyes how come
we're not seeing the little points of
light all the time how come particularly
when there's very little light and when
it's very dark how come when it's dark
do we not start seeing does that does
our visual scene not start being little
points of light coming in rather than
just oh i can barely see it why is it
the case why isn't it the case that it's
like oh i see a little you know a little
that was a photon that came in there
that was a photon that came in there and
so on
okay the it's actually slightly
mysterious why we don't see that and it
has is more a feature of our visual
perception than it's a feature of the
physics of light and the reason we don't
see it presumably is because
our
uh
our
we have um sort of nerves that
cross-connect between these different um
uh these different photoreceptors on our
retina and those do a certain amount of
averaging and so it is even though at
sort of at the lowest level there would
be individual cells in our retina that
are that are sort of being excited by
these photons of light where
the the kind of net of nerves that even
exists in our retina averages the
effects of those different individual
photoreceptors and so we never we the
things that we sense never corresponds
to things where we can actually see
individual like individual photons
now you know the architecture of our
eyes you know the the eye of the
compound valley of the type we have has
evolved three four times
uh separately in the course of
biological history
and uh things like i think the king crab
has a different lineage of its compound
eye it's the same idea it has
photoreceptors things we do um but it's
i
seems to have evolved in a different
path it's sort of differently emerged
from from lower level visual perception
uh apparatus
and it doesn't have a mistake that we
have in our eye in our eye
um the photoreceptors are on the back
and um there is in front of the
photoreceptors are some of the
connections between the photoreceptors
and that absorbs some of the light that
we would otherwise be able to see
the the king crowd i guess um really put
a premium on
being able to see well because it lives
in the you know deep enough in the ocean
there really isn't very much light there
and so it
uh it managed to get this right and has
the cross connections behind the
restaurant which means that it is more
sensitive to light than we are and i
think the claim is that that um
um
there are at least
uh king crab can should be able to sense
kind of well the very least like a 50
photon lump of of light but
distributed across its whole retina so
that probably means that if if we were
king crabs we probably already know
about photons because uh
one might suspect that the perception
system of the crab um actually uh is
sensitive would perceive low light
levels in terms of individual photons
coming in the way that we do not
um
so
now
uh
that's the case for for
so sorry in other words you can't sort
of discover the quantization of light
you can't discover the fact that you can
think of light in terms of photons by of
is your perception because we're doing
all this averaging which is specifically
making us not notice that there are sort
of individual packets of light coming in
um
now
there are there are cases in which you
can see
um
the equivalent of when you
uh okay so so when you have uh when it's
not just your eyes uh for example when
you have a photo multiplier tube so how
do you detect
uh a photon
you
um let's see that actually we want a
different um
um
well for example
let's take maybe we shouldn't get into
this particular radical i was going to
talk about night vision systems
and um uh things where you have an
effect of a photon comes in
and um it's a little bit like what
happens in in our retina the the photon
is converted to an electrical signal and
then what happens is you're amplifying
that electrical signal there are a
variety of ways that can happen
um and uh
you're using electric fields magnetic
fields to sort of amplify the the um uh
in different cases it's done in
different ways um to to amplify that
electrical signal it's very hard if you
have a photon if you have some light
um there's there's no easy way to just
um increase you know you've got some
light coming along there's no easy way
to sort of increase the light signal
directly
for an electrical signal there are ways
to amplify the electrical signal to kind
of
feed in more more energy and effect into
the electrical signal to produce to make
it a a um a higher signal um and uh
there are a variety of ways to do that
that are
and so that's why one tends to do
amplification in electrical terms not um
not in terms of light you can do
amplification of light with lasers
effectively um that's a that's again a
separate story
all right a little bit on that
uh
let's see
amenities asks
if the level of carbon dioxide in the
earth's atmosphere was much higher in
the past
why wasn't there a runaway greenhouse
effect back then
i don't know for sure
one thing you can certainly see
we have data
from a variety of sources
that give us an indication of the carbon
dioxide and oxygen levels in the earth's
atmosphere and the average temperature
um
uh going back
throughout geological time
and so
um
i don't recall the the exact time i
think in the times of the dinosaurs that
become the outside level may have been
higher substantially higher um
certainly the earth has changed a whole
bunch over time the the temperature of
the surface has changed um there are ice
ages even even in recorded history even
in the 1600s there was kind of a little
ice stage and you know rivers that
nowadays are sort of free-flowing rivers
um in northern europe for example were
frozen over for 50 years and things um
it never got warm enough to to um uh to
melt that ice so that was i think 1650s
if i remember correctly around that time
there was kind of a little ice age um
that uh um
that had an effect and there are all
kinds of strange correlations between
for example solar activity sunspot
activity um things like that um there's
effects like that there are effects to
do with the the uh precise distance that
the earth is and it's orbit away from
the sun and there's cycles and the tens
of thousands of years range
of that so there are a variety of these
kinds of very externalized
effects that
that can have a can have an effect on on
the earth's average temperature and
things like this
then there are features that are more to
do with the the biosphere part of the
earth i mean you know uh plants uh you
know absorb carbon dioxide animals
produce carbon dioxide things like this
um i think that the um
uh
the question of of what i i should
explain something which is that
the the reason okay so there's this
phenomenon the so-called greenhouse
effect i should explain that
so in a greenhouse that is you know a
glass a glass sort of um
you know
shed or whatever it is that in which you
grow plants and things you are you've
got you know it has a transparent roof
but that roof is it's transparent to
visible light you can see through it
and
the um uh and the sun
light from the sun
which most of the light from the sun is
visible light
the light from the sun perfectly well
goes through the glass just like we can
see through the glass light can get
through the glass ordinary light can get
through the glass
the problem is that once that light so
the light comes in from the glass
when that light
the energy from that light heats things
up
those things they get hot and they are
when they get hot they also emit
something light light but it's infrared
light
so let me try to explain this
so whenever you have a hot object
it is uh you know heat
is all the the what heat means is it's
the energy of all the molecules bouncing
around
inside the material that is what
corresponds to heat and the sort of that
that um the energy the average energy
associated with all the molecules
bouncing around that determines the
temperature
so
what happens is that as all these atoms
keep on colliding with each other and
things like that
the the effect of those collisions
is to make the atoms uh emit light and
they do that because the atoms get um
they
because the electrons inside the atoms
um get
in
they get sort of kicked into it excited
state and then they emit light when they
and they decay down to the ground state
again but in case the basic effect is
when there's when there's all this uh uh
you're you're producing
these um
uh you're you're you're producing uh
photons of light but now the question is
as you
change
the um
as you change the temperature
uh what how does the spectrum of light
that you produce change
and what happens is this was discovered
around 1900 um what happens is there's
the so-called planck spectrum
named after max planck p-l-p-l-a-n-c-k
um
planck spectrum
um and what what happens is
that the
this so you get light
or more accurately electromagnetic
radiation photons whatever you want to
describe it as you get essentially
photons of a range of different energies
produced
and
the
a low energy photon
is something that will be well the
electromagnetic spectrum goes from
photons of very low energy to photons of
very high energy that's equivalent to
saying that the light waves have very uh
long wavelength low frequency to very
short wavelength high frequency um but
um
the the different kinds of so you go
from uh very low energy
uh long wavelength low frequency that's
radio waves as you move up to sort of
higher energy shorter wavelengths etc
you
get to infrared light
then you get to this very narrow band of
visible light
then you go to ultraviolet then you go
to x-rays gamma rays
so
the depending on the temperature of
something it will tend to emit photons
that have a certain that have energies
in a certain range and they never it
never emits
photons with a very specific energy
something like a laser or something like
um uh
a a specific well let's not get into
that they
they're
you you can set things up so that you
are emitting like a sodium lamp emits
photons of a very specific wavelength
but a very specific energy but when
you're just heating things up and you're
using sort of uh heat
and just sort of random
bouncings around of atoms to produce
these photons they will be have a
distribution of energies
and that distribution of energies will
have a certain peak there'll be a an
energy where there'll be a an energy
that they'll be most popular energy and
there'll be some distribution of
energies okay so what happens is when
you have a thing with low temperature
it's producing very uh low energy
photons
and as you move up the the the
temperature the average
energy of the photons that get produced
gets progressively higher
okay so a key factor is around 6 500
degrees
um
well six six thousand uh
uh let's see there'll be sixty 800
degrees centigrade um
the uh no i'm sorry 6200
degrees centigrade
around 6000 degrees 6500 degrees
when you have a thing that is at that
temperature
it's
the the peak
uh energy of photons produced
corresponds to
uh the sort of the center of the visible
light spectrum and in fact there's a
distribution of energies of photons and
that distribution of energies goes from
photons that correspond to red light to
photons that correspond to blue light
and everything in between
uh kind of a whole rainbow of
of light
of different of different colors
and those
uh those frequencies at
6500 degrees roughly um the
something will produce
will be
uh if you were to look at the thing as
you heat it up it will look white hot
and that is it looks white hot because
it is emitting photons with a
distribution of energy's distribution of
frequencies that corresponds pretty much
to
the the range of colors that we see in
invisible light so just to explain that
the the different colors correspond to
different frequencies of light different
energies of photons
uh low energy the lower energy end is
red light the higher energy end is is uh
blue light
um and that's if you go outside the
range where our eyes can actually detect
the light you go on the red end you go
towards infrared on the on the blue end
you go towards ultraviolet
okay so light from the sun is
concentrated in this range of energies
of photons that corresponds to visible
light
okay when when the light is coming
through the greenhouse roof
and heats up your pots of the plotted
plants or whatever it is um it is
those pots
don't get heated up to 6000 degrees
uh better not at least
um and so those hot those pots because
they're hot
are also emitting electromagnetic
radiation
but it's not visible light it's much
lower frequency radiation it's infrared
radiation
and the issue is that so light's coming
in through the greenhouse roof the
greenhouse roof is transparent to
visible light
but then what's happening is that
visible light
is being is heating up the energy from
that visible light is heating up the
pots or whatever it is in the greenhouse
those things are themselves emitting
radiation but it's infrared radiation of
much lower frequency much lower energy
per photon okay so what
well the point is that the greenhouse
which is transparent to visible light is
not transparent to infrared light and so
when that when that uh the energy comes
in through the greenhouse roof in
visible light it's then converted to
energy that is uh associated with these
lower frequency photons these infrared
photons and the infrared photons then
get stuck in the greenhouse
because they can no longer they they
can't um they can't escape because the
the um the greenhouse is not transparent
to um
uh
to that infrared light now there are a
couple of other effects that have to do
with the um
uh
well there's also convection and let's
not get into that but the basic effect
is that um you can you can the light
in the form of that it comes from the
sun the frequency that comes from the
sun can get into the greenhouse
but the heat which is lower frequency
can't get out of the greenhouse and so
therefore uh you just get more and more
energy comes into the greenhouse but it
can't get out of the greenhouse and so
the greenhouse heats up
and the bad case for
our planet
probably
is that the same thing happens there
and there are things in the atmosphere
like carbon dioxide that can make
the um
uh that can have the effect that again
light can come up can can the light from
the sun can heat up the surface of the
earth but the infrared light from the
heat from the subs of the earth can't
escape um back into space again and so
on average the temperature of the
surface of the earth heats up now there
are many things that can affect that for
example if you put
aerosols into the upper atmosphere
or all kinds of things into the upper
atmosphere that
reflect the light before it ever gets to
the surface then you can change the
amount of light that gets the surface of
the earth and you can change the
temperature so for example what happened
um in the time of the dinosaurs at the
end of the time of the dinosaurs when
the
uh 65 million years ago when the
asteroid hit the earth that um wiped out
the dinosaurs or at least put the final
last was the final last story wiping out
the dinosaurs
one of the things that one of the
effects that had was it through dust up
into the upper atmosphere of the earth
and for a year or two the um the
the upper atmosphere was just
it was it was full of dust and so light
from the sun couldn't reach the surface
of the earth and so the earth
dramatically cooled down and if you're a
cold-blooded dinosaur um that's that's
bad news at that point
um
and so
uh
it isn't the case that um
you know at a different time in the in
the in dinosaur history um there was i
think a high carbon dioxide
concentration and um you know the the
the the kind of joke thing to say would
be well maybe that proves that the
dinosaurs had developed an industrial
civilization where they were you know
burning coal from the carboniferous
period or something um we just don't
know because all of that stuff was
destroyed we never found any evidence of
it but really um you know that was
evidence of it but that's nonsense
that's not what was going on um
presumably
the uh
uh
so i i don't know
my guess would be that one of the things
that limits carbon dioxide uh production
um and
in the earth for the earth and there are
there are different sources of different
kinds of gases like volcanoes are source
of gases and there are biological
sources um one of the things that i
would guess is that the more carbon
dioxide you have the happier the plants
are and so the more plants grow and the
more algae in the ocean you know emerge
to be able to process things and so on
and there's a whole sort of chemistry
that that can can change
um and certainly in in you know i think
the the typical um
uh
piece of carbon
uh that is in sort of the sort of the
cycle that happens on the earth
where there's carbon in the rocks on the
earth
and that there's carbon um that gets um
the carbon dioxide and and i think it
spends like hundreds of millions of
years
uh the carbon spends sort of uh you know
in
in the rock as one of the constituents
of the rock and only it's for some very
brief period of history does it end up
with carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
and i think it's normally reabsorbed
through the oceans um and uh and then
ends up back in the rock that forms
sedimentary rock that forms from the
ocean and so on and it ends up spending
sort of most of its life in rock so to
speak and only occasionally sort of
emerges into the atmosphere but my guess
is that there's a lot of it in the
atmosphere there are more plants
that um happily grow
now of course in modern times where
we're sort of humans are in charge so to
speak people will say i don't want
plants to grow all over
uh you know this place where i'm trying
to grow crops or something i don't want
giant trees there but i don't want um uh
you know plants to go in the middle of
my uh you know on
in some place where
um you know on my airport runway or
something like this so i mean i think
that that
what might be otherwise something where
plants just grow wherever they can grow
and you know certainly many parts of the
world had many more trees in the past
than they do today and one of the one of
the things that humans have done
is in in in
uh in the development of agriculture
when you're growing crops you don't want
a bunch of trees there you want a
plowable field um rather than covered
with trees and so you know a lot of the
us for example used to be covered with
trees
and then was turned into farmland
um which is necessary if you're going to
to support you know the the i think
people estimate that um
uh sort of if you are just a
hunter-gatherer where you're not doing
agriculture you're not um uh you're not
um you don't have crops that you have
specifically sort of uh specifically
growing you know the earth might be able
to support 10 million people um very
different from what you get when you
actually have crops and agriculture and
sort of an organized food production
effort so you kind of you know that's um
that's the that's what you get in order
to do that um according to what we
currently the current agricultural
practice
you can't have a bunch of trees there
you need light from the sun getting to
your to your crops on a field and you
need to be able to you know plow your
field and so on
right long long answer that question
let's see uh
um
okay
um
uh pauline is commenting about some the
limestone absorbs carbonic acid rain so
that's acid rain scrubbing carbon
dioxide the atmosphere that takes
forever you know people
people i've certainly heard that there's
a mineral called olivine which is a
green mineral that's pretty common and
i've certainly heard that
um if you put it
if you put that like on beaches
and um you let it interact with the
ocean and so on that it is a much more
efficient absorber of carbon dioxide and
i you know i had heard that people who
were you know sort of saying they were
going to make all the earth screech
beaches green with olivine and it was
going to solve any problems with carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere that was a few
years ago i haven't heard more about it
so so something must have gone wrong
with that scheme i think but but people
certainly there's certainly some pieces
of of chemistry that
are can be thought about in those in
those terms
um
two curves asks
do the electron orbitals of an atom ever
rotate
do they rotate at the same rate of the
nucleus or independently
uh okay is this the same property as
electron spin are different
okay a lot of stuff to unpack there
all right what is an electron orbital
so
the general picture of an atom is
there's a nucleus in the center it's
made of uh you know protons and neutrons
it's pretty small
and then
uh the
the nucleus might have a certain uh size
and let's say a hundred thousand let's
say the size of the nucleus is one unit
well a hundred thousand units out
is where
uh the electrons that are part of the
atom
are sort of localized
so in an atom
the the nucleus with protons in it is a
positively charged nucleus
and it attracts electrons which are
negatively charged electrical
electricity electrical forces have the
uh uh uh have the feature that um um
unlike charges attract like charges
repel two two protons will repel each
other electrically but a proton with
positive charge an electron with
negative charge will attract each other
electrically different for gravity for
example for gravity uh
everything attracts but for electricity
um things which have
like charges both plus charges repel
that things with opposite charges
attract
okay so in
a um
in an atom
there will be
the nucleus with positive charge and it
will be attracting the electrons and the
pulling electrons saying you know get
electrons come and come and be part of
this atom so to speak so for example a
hydrogen atom most common form of a
hydrogen atom just one proton in the
center and one electron one might say
sort of going around that proton
and when people first started thinking
about this about 120 years ago um sort
of the picture was more or less the
electron would be attracted to the
nucleus much like a planet is attracted
to the sun and the electron would be
sort of orbiting the nucleus um like a
planet or what's the sun
now that picture turns out to be very
much too simplistic but some of the
terminology like the term orbitals comes
from that picture
um okay so why is that picture uh sort
of um
uh too simplistic the real reason is
because of quantum mechanics
the
um uh
so let's see how to explain this um
so quantum mechanics
is this kind of very fundamental fact
about
uh things like electrons
and it says that whereas
in ordinary physics we think oh the
planet moved in exactly this way it's
just one thing the planet did quantum
mechanics says you shouldn't think about
things that way you should think about
all the possible things the electron
might have done
and that all those different histories
oh the electron was in this place it was
in that place it was moving that way it
was moving this way all those different
things that the electron might have done
they're all things that in some sense
all really happen
and they're all there's sort of many
parallel threads of history and uh for
for the universe and for the electron
and every one of those threads of
history is really happening
now the question is why do we think that
definite things happen that's a very
tricky issue that has confused people
for a long time and i think in in our
recent models of physics we're beginning
to have a an understanding of that and
it's a little bit of a strange thing
because the in a sense
the reason we think definite things
happen
at some level is sort of total logically
because we think definite things happen
what do i mean by that well there are
all these different threads of history
these electrons doing all these
different possible things but our brain
is also doing all these different
possible things so the question of what
we perceive the electron to be doing is
a question of what this sort of all the
parallel threads all this sort of
branching threads of history
of what our brain is doing how all of
those perceive all these branching
threads of history of what the electron
is doing
and so the important thing is that we we
think that definite things happen so
even though there might be parallel
threads of history associated with our
brain we kind of conflate all those
threads together and the big fact about
quantum mechanics is that we don't run
into inconsistencies by doing that
in other words if we just sort of assume
they're all the same
um then we don't end up with with uh uh
that doesn't lead us to sort of a global
um inconsistency this is complicated
stuff and what i'm describing is kind of
the sort of the leading edge of things
that we figured out in the last few
years in our project to understand
fundamental physics
um the uh but the sort of the the
traditional
well
what comes out of this is the electron
is doing all these possible things
and so you can describe kind of that
there's a certain chance a certain
probability for the electron to do any
particular thing
and there are equations that describe
kind of what the density of probability
is for the electrons to do one thing or
another and so in particular there's a
thing of the schrodinger equation
invented by owen schoninger in the 1920s
which is an equation that tells you more
or less the probability that an electron
will for example be at a certain
position relative to the nucleus of an
atom
uh i'm lighting a couple of technical
details here but that's more or less
what happens and so that equation
tells one okay the this electron
can okay so one feature of that equation
is that it describes a possible uh
probability distribution for the
electron
but what it does is it describes a
discrete set of possible probability
distributions so let me give you an
analogy to this
so when you have something like a string
and you pluck the string
one thing you can do is to pluck the
string and it makes it kind of bows out
and there's just one bowing out from if
you if you attach the two ends of this
of this of the string
you can also uh pluck the string so that
you end up with two um two set of peaks
in the string or three or four but you
can't end up with three and a half
because you've attached um the string at
one at both ends both ends have to be
you know in a particular place but in
the middle this this string can make
makes a sine wave um it can make a sine
wave of uh with kind of
a wavelength of one just you know bows
out once or two it does it twice three
does it three times uh sort of one
wiggle two wiggles three wiggles but you
can never get like three and a half
wiggles
it's the same thing with the stronger
equation with atoms that you end up with
something where the this probability
distribution for the electron can be
kind of a one wiggle probability
distribution or two wiggles or three
wiggles and so on and those correspond
to what people describe as the different
orbitals for a an atom they correspond
to different
uh different kind of
states for the electron now in each of
those states what's really going on is a
certain is a distribution of way exactly
where the electron is found so for
example
in the uh lowest state the state with
the lowest energy the state
um
you the distribution is such that the
in a hydrogen atom for example
that the electron on average is a
certain distance the so-called bore
radius away from the the proton at the
center of the atom and that distance is
about um uh 110 billionth of a meter
so that's the but there's a distribution
of distances it can be that's the
average but sometimes if you really were
able to figure out exactly where where
was that electron but it was actually a
little bit closer to the nucleus a
little bit further away from the nucleus
but that's that's the um that's the way
it works now one feature of that lowest
level
uh orbital that lowest level state is
that it is spherically symmetric that is
the probability to find the electron is
the same in all orientations relative to
the relative to the nucleus
okay as you go to the next state up the
first excited state that's no longer
true
what then happens is that the
uh
it's a little complicated okay
so
uh
yeah so i i mentioned with this with a
string you can have one wiggle two
wiggles three wiggles etc
um when you end up
with sort of a distribution of things on
the sphere it's a little bit more
complicated than that a string it's just
like one dimension you're wiggling once
twice etc if you imagine putting things
on the surface of a sphere and you're
coloring the surface of a sphere and one
way you can color it it's just uniform
color
another thing you can do is say
uh you're going to have the equivalence
of one wiggle but that corresponds to a
certain coloring of the sphere
and it turns out
that
you end up with sort of three distinct
kinds of colorings as the next level of
coloring after just the uniform color
and um so you know technically those are
the um uh they're called spherical
harmonics so the mathematics of this is
on a in in one dimension the so-called
orthogonal polynomials are sine and
cosine functions
and on the surface of a sphere the
orthogonal polynomials are the spherical
harmonics which are related to things
like those things called the genre
functions
but in any case the the basic point is
that the uh
what happens is that when you say i've
got an electron and what state can it be
in well it can be in the lowest state
which is spherically symmetric it can be
in one of it turns out three possible
next level states and those three
possible next level states have
probability distributions that kind of
um you know that they kind of split out
in different directions so what do i
mean by that i mean the chances are
for example the electron is thinking
about the spheres like the earth the
electron is most of the time at the
north pole or the south pole that's one
of the one of the things that is sort of
the next level
of uh possible distribution of
probabilities for where the electron is
or there's another possibility it could
be on one side of the equator or the
opposite side of the equator
or the same thing 90 degrees off those
are different possible sort of
independent
configurations that independent
states that the electron can be here and
so those things are called orbitals
uh for various reasons the the um the
lowest level state the one that's
spherical symmetric is called the s
orbital these are named after german
words that come from the
oh come from spectroscopy they come from
the um
the light that's emitted when when
electrons transition from one of these
uh states to another state
but in any case the the thing that um uh
so what then happens is
the uh the next level so the s orbitals
are the lowest ones the next ones are p
orbitals yes it's in german so i don't
know exactly what the words were but um
uh uh the next one is d orbitals f
orbitals um and so each successive uh as
as you get to higher energies for the
electron it it is it has a distant
distribution of positions relative to
the nucleus and so when you see pictures
in chemistry books for example of
electron orbitals they typically will
sort of
they'll be a thing which kind of comes
out
in you know let's say towards the north
pole and southwest it's like two big
jets coming out from the north pole and
south pole what that's doing is it's
plotting uh it's a little bit confusing
perhaps it's plotting
um
the as a function of direction it's
plotting the probability that an
electron is found there as the distance
from the center
so it's not really how the electron is
arranged it's just saying that's the
probability
that
the um uh that that's the um
probability distribution for the
electron is such that it is more likely
to be found at the north and south poles
so
let's see that's that's some so you okay
so then it gets even more complicated
because
uh oh my
um
let's see
the thing is
when you prepare an atom
you say i've i'm making an atom it comes
out of a chemical reaction it comes out
of something else
the question is
um
are the electrons in it
in that atom
oh dear this is complicated um
we've talked about the fact that there
are sort of three distinct states
that electrons that have uh that are in
these p orbitals can uh be associated
with
now the thing that's tricky is those
those states are really just probability
distributions each one is just the
probability distribution for the one
that is going straight up and down the
one that's left right the one that's in
out whatever those are all just certain
probability distributions
now
in the end
uh an electron
can be
and this is where sort of the story of
quantum mechanics comes in it can be in
a so-called superposition
of those states
and
again i'm kind of cheating a little bit
because
the the superposition thing is adding up
what are called quantum amplitudes and
the probabilities i've been talking
about are the squares of quantum
amplitudes there's a little bit of
wiggling around here but roughly
when an electron when an atom is
produced in some way there will be some
mixture and let's say the electron is
has the energy that corresponds to the p
orbital
there'll still be some mixture of the x
and y and z
uh orbitals that the electron uh
when you prepare an atom there'll be
some amount of you know
your combining probabilities that we sum
out of the x orbital some amount of the
y some amount of the z
um and so when an atom is just let's say
an atom is produced in a chemical
reaction
um the electron will be in some
superposition some combination of x y
and z
uh uh those x y and z states
and um
so
uh when you say what is the probability
distribution it'll be it'll be a mixture
of those states and so it'll be some
some probability distribution that's
some fraction of one plus some fraction
of the other and so on
now
uh
how does that probability distribution
evolve
this is quite complicated how does it
evolve with time for example
oh boy this is complicated
the issue is that this probability
distribution is a stationary state
that is if you have an atom
and you leave it for a really long time
it will be in this s orbital state the p
orbital states and so on those are
states that things are in after a long
time so imagine that the analogy with a
string okay so you've got the string and
eventually the string will just be in
this state where it's let's say bowing
it has two wiggles in it for example
but it could be
that
it got to that state by you
you know using a bow
and um uh and kind of you know
sort of
pulling the string of one particular
part of the string the string was
flapping around in all kinds of ways and
eventually it ended up being in exactly
this um this sort of so-called eigen
mode um this thing where it always stays
eigen is german for same where it always
stays the same in some sense
um and uh
but it it can take a while to get if you
just say what happens immediately it may
not be in one of these staying the same
states so these orbitals for example are
the conditions that atoms get into when
they are when it's an atom which is
that's the way the atom is and it's
going to be that way forever so to speak
when an atom first emerges from a
chemical reaction or something like that
it
um
it's a slightly different description
and
in that case the um
this is going to get complicated and i
think i think we're going to run out of
time here but but let me try to address
um
uh
um
this question had to do with the
rotation of electron orbitals and that
is a really complicated story um because
these orbitals are just sort of a
picture version of some mathematics
that's going on and the thing i'm
backing into explaining is that
mathematics but maybe i shouldn't go
there and let me just explain a couple
other things
so
ah yeah this is complicated okay
so the
lots of things kind of spin around
so for example the nucleus of an atom
can spin around its axis just like the
earth spins around its axis an electron
can spin around its axis
in fact every electron spins around its
axis at a certain rate now it's a little
confusing because electrons are
thought to have although i don't think
this is really true but um in in sort of
the traditional view in physics has been
electrons intrinsically have zero size
but they don't have zero angular
momentum so if you have a top for
example spinning around it has has a
certain uh
angular momentum uh that's a
a um
the you know velocity as a
it it
will keep spinning because of
conservation of angular momentum
and an electron it's zero size but it
has non-zero angular momentum so it's a
little confusing
but that that's a feature of of what is
observed in physics
uh i think we now are beginning to know
from our fundamental theory of physics
why that might work that way but in the
past it's just been it's just a fact
that electrons have non-zero momentum
even though they have zero size
so
the thing that um
that happens
is that these different orbitals i've
been talking about
they are also associated with
uh
angular momentum
and um
so confusing
because
you know when we think about tops
spinning around we're used to the idea
that you can look at the points on the
top oh it spun around to a different
place
it moved
okay
unfortunately the
the meaning of angular momentum in
quantum mechanics
is a little bit more abstract than that
and worse than that
when we're dealing with with atoms
and we're saying we're talking about
these orbitals these eigenstates we're
thinking about atoms that are kind of in
in a stationary state where there's sort
of nothing quotes moving
and so it's it's a
this is a this is a tricky
tricky story
um
and uh let me think about this how to
say this
um
yeah i mean
you see the question of saying oh
there's an individual electron and it's
whizzing around the atom
that isn't really the right picture
because of this point about all these
different possible histories uh
occurring sort of at the same time yeah
i think i think i have to i probably
have to punt on this because i'm i'm um
um there's a
maybe i can come back to this another
time um
the uh
i i i have to explain a whole bunch of
stuff about the way that quantum
mechanics
deals with angular momentum
and um i mean the end result is
that
when you think of a top spinning around
you can kind of measure the speed that
the top moves at the outer part of the
top moves at that is a feature of
classical physics
in quantum mechanics you can't do
something like that you can't say oh
i've got an electron oh it has an
angular momentum that means that i can
look at a point on the electron and see
it moving around doesn't work that way
not least because the electron is
thought to be of zero size um the
meaning of angular momentum is a little
bit more abstract than just you can see
a point on the thing and it's moving
around
now uh the
it can be the case
yeah so so
um and that's why one has to kind of
understand more about what anger
momentum means in quantum mechanics
and um uh in the end
there is
angular momentum that there are
different kinds of angular momentum
there's then yeah there's i mean just to
say the technical terms
the um uh these orbitals are associated
with what's called orbital angle
momentum which is kind of roughly uh the
concept of the sort of an electron at a
certain distance and it is it has um it
it's not really moving in the same sense
um
yeah this is it's a mess
um the the there's one of these cases
where it's sort of um
a little frustrating because
if i were just talking about this in
terms of the mathematics of quantum
mechanics
although the mathematics is a little bit
fancy um this is all pretty well defined
when it comes to interpreting it and
explaining it
in sort of everyday physics terms that
we're all used to where we're used to
sort of our everyday experience of the
world it gets more difficult because
quantum mechanics is not our everyday
experience of the world it's something
different
all right well i think i have to wrap up
here because i have to go back to my
day job um
and uh i look forward to continuing next
week and thank you for these questions i
think today we had a rather
uh
sort of physics-oriented collection of
questions
i'm happy to um as i say i i always
learn things by trying to explain them
here and
thank you for these questions and some
challenges here
all right gotta go now